das geht nicht wenn jemand glaube der
ist wirklich wirklich zu kraft
inzwischen auch schon mitbekommen leute
an jeder ecke hört man dieser tage was
von der donut kette reul donuts die
haben während alle läden im letzten jahr
quasi geschlossen waren 82 neue filialen
in deutschland aufgemacht man sieht
überall auf tik tok in den zeitungen
habe ich mir gedacht test sich die mal
für euch habe ich meinen bruder max
zusammengetan um gefühlt einmal die
ganze produkt pleite fürchtet testen das
ganze ist eskaliert ich war wirklich
geschockt von dem ergebnis also schauen
dass wir bis zum ende und jetzt
deutungen uns die donuts ab
[Musik]
wir haben noch zwei spitzen
sie sind richtig kraft das hier doch in
der auslage sieht schon ziemlich crazy
aus günter weber sich das diabolo
anzuordnen ems leute oder wird es zu
crazy gebt euch das leben einfach zwei
boxen hier das ist wirklich genug um
eine großfamilie für drei wochen zu
erlernen was drin ist so niermann mit
fester heute am mir also gebro den
kalorien für 15 jahre
ja ja du hast alles schon gesehen
ja ich hab ich den sorgen kann dass das
darunter drücken dass dieses kittler wir
schon comcom kompakt geblieben war es
sieht schon sagt raster das richtig sein
dass das werde für die erbin alter
schwede das ist ja nicht mehr von dieser
welt erich schwartze ich glaube ich habe
noch nie so mit goldstaub und einer
spritze zum injizieren von utah oder
diamanten drauf
also ich schwöre ich kann das noch gar
nicht so richtig hätte doch nicht so ein
schönes sind gerade ehrlich überrascht
das ist ja das sind ja kleine kunstwerke
ja vor wie vor ist alles drauf was
himbeere so goldstaub
ich bin ich bin radio kino joy
das habe ich ewigkeiten nicht mehr
gesehen überhaupt so und jetzt doppelt
so groß alter kann man hier sondern ein
kleines fenster drin
[Musik]
auch diese summe zu leisten böse so ein
bischen reis christie's mit dienste sind
auch durch ort der der wird mal was sage
ich hallo wäre sage ich ja schon ich bin
ja der blaue permanent für mich ja auch
froh dass das wetter anfangs zu essen
ganz kurz ich probiert es mal alles zu
identifizieren das hier ist so ein
gockel madonna tja das hier ist wild
wayne mit welchen bären
hier trocken wir von kinder die mit
haselnuss krokant happy hippo oh mein
gott
baseball ist das hier ist wirklich
komplett pervers das ist es was wir sind
wir als erste rief er ihr dass es war
die basic ist würde sagen einfach monat
wobei ein alter da draußen die meisten
der schokolade ist einfach hau drauf
sagt er du das ding ist der grill darauf
legen könnt halt nicht alles probieren
ja maximal hälfte daher genauso das hier
ist so das benchmark bei einer guten
pizzeria ist meine pizza margherita
einen guten draht laden ist mannschaften
also prosit neujahr sehr sehr flache
klassischer donnert geruch geil
jakob dankbarer weise wird also dann für
die elliptischen keine knusprige
schokolade es gibt ja häufig bei der
soko springer
da will ich nicht so ist ja die dann
aber auch noch so eine glasschicht und
du kannst so diedorf werke bei uns haben
sie auch mal gegen langdorf becker
fluffy monats müssen so sein dass man
die so mit kaffee wegspülen kann und das
ist bei diesem jahr das ist nicht so
diese das ist diese so fettig
schokoladen ich habe gehört schon meine
finger direkt von der queen die wenn das
war die creme braucht also wieder
aufnehmen der das ist wirklich zu krank
um auch mal was ins maul
die naht von jesus um das uns toppen das
ist kein bug in oregon
das ist ein krone hat man sieht dass
hier ist das hier ist blätterteig noch
niemals den kronrat gegessen jetzt
erstmal mit
ich habe ein bisschen so ein schauer
bekommt würde das heute wenn man so was
ist wirklich also mit diesem blätterteig
janele soße brown boveri auch immer mehr
als ein ist muss man so ins krankenhaus
das ist ein fakt leitet also das ist auf
jeden fall schon so eine tödliche dosis
willst dabei ein glas das noch so gerade
voll auf mich und ganzen eine ganz neue
erfahrung das ist noch noch
komprimierter dadurch dass das so
blätterteig griechenland es ist noch
krasser irgendwie auf jeden fall leute
diese krone hat also mit diesem blättert
kann man fett empfiehlt diesen richtig
geil ich für den nächsten colin teleskop
ich würde den nehmen aber dass auch ein
kleiner tja dementsprechend ich geh auch
ich gehe auch einen special mit spritze
war das ist kein nicht nur kinder das
ist ja das runter also man entwickelt
schuldgefühle wenn man das ist kein spaß
beim fressen
wir müssen auch mental dafür vorbereitet
sein leute ist kein spaß ist von den
zutaten her nicht so komplett meister
job ein bisschen diesig 100 prozent ja
wäre das ist komplett meint brockmann
wird meine wafer hier machen dass hier
ohne mich auch im sinne des seht ihr
wieder klebt trocken mich durchaus
positive der kritiker ich muss richtig
kämpfen
das ist wirklich so ich kann meinen mund
wieder auch zu machen halte ich das weiß
nenne ich mir die kamera gehalten weil
er geht wo ich bin einfach nur noch dann
wiederum so money boy aber das ist ja
einfach crazy recht haben auch langsam
nicht mehr aber okay junge okay du
kannst dich aufhören es geht weiter mal
der detox das geht nicht mal jemand
glaube die beiden sind zwei fische der
es wirklich wirklich zu kraft ja ich
will doch nicht vertreiben leute aber
der ist wirklich zu krass der ist die
klassische 20 von 22 wird weiter
gebraucht so exponential funktionen und
diese zahl zu beschneiden
das ist krank er ist das ist meiner der
ist so krank er ist noch viel krasser
ja weil wenn ich so also meine
persönliche meinung ist das ist alles
was zuviel hier ist so und das ist so
die perfekte milliarden ja das kann man
auch bewältigen das andere kann man ja
nicht schneiden so dennis leute wenn sie
auf einer sonder pizza zu viel drauf was
man kann ihn nicht schneiden so dass ein
arzt wir geben wechseln kurz auf die
intensivstation
jakob sagen wie lange wir schon auf 13
minuten 13
wir können nicht alle hier alle
gerechnet was wir da und ich merke dass
gerade das macht wissen aber es geht
nicht wie kann man nicht so viel essen
ist hier ja diese markt wo leute so wie
ich sowas weghauen aber ich will gar
nicht wissen es hat dann halt nichts
mehr mit genuss zu tun
wir wollen das ja genießen der ganze
next level ich habe auch freunde von mir
bescheid gegeben dass ich dieses video
heute drehe und habe schon abnehmer für
die ganze dort gefunden was ich keine
sorgen machen
lasst noch 1 1 oder 2 also wenn ihr euch
so komplett umbauen wollte dann nimmt
man würde ich mal den vorschlagen oder
den der iss zu ich habe angst vor denen
ich sag's ehrlich so okay leute mag hat
schon den nächsten kroner dass das glaub
ich mit croissant gesperrt da wo es
wirklich sinn des überflutung also geld
verstehen wenn er das auch machen das
ist also ich hätte auch jeder von den
donots hat mindestens 500 kalorien
das kann nicht sein leben sei ich
schwöre ich könnte mir vorstellen wenn
man das so alleine ist es werden
kalorien für diesen tag ist also
wirklich jeder diese normalen donuts der
schulrat von 5 an kalorien glaube ich so
was hab ich nix denn glücklich sollte
das noch einen zähler
ich hoffe wir können wir teilen uns
diese ecke ganz ganz schwere nummer hoch
ich schwöre ich glaube meine zahnärzte
hat mir geschrieben gehoben so und wie
kann da die kann
wie kann da auch noch sind so auch so
eine geile art und weise durchkommt das
ist endstufe dass es komplett endstufe
skate ist wirklich crazy ich war aber
mehr geht auch nicht mein bach will man
noch mehr machen ja also kannst du nicht
mehr rein machen also du kannst
vielleicht noch dass ich mir einmal kann
sie mehr drauf machen es ist einfach
endstufe kannst auch so zutaten entwürfe
komprimieren müllpresse style dann geht
noch mehr sein aber das ist wirklich zu
realisieren
doch das wurde auch schon angewandt
diesen verwendet sich zumindest wegen
der müllhalde gerade aber es war jede
sekunde und jedem bissen wer wirklich
krass class krass ich wusste nicht dass
das so heftig dass ich dachte es sei
also ja sie ist sowieso da ist ja aber
das ist wirklich nächste level leute die
war 3 auf jeden fall komplett diese
blaubär sind auch so geil ich schwöre
ich muss jetzt im winterschlaf einlegen
ich habe beim reden sowieso speichert er
zu krank
es ist wirklich zu können also leute da
diese videos so eine sicherheitswarnung
geben ernährt euch gesund so was geht
mal natürlich nicht jeden tag und macht
euch darauf gefasst also ich finds krank
max water anderen leid